my palace sources are telling me that
yesterday which was Commonwealth Day at
Westminster Abbey was Duchess Megan's
last official engagement in the diary
making Markel is starting to slow down
her work schedule as she gears up to
become a mom while she will be doing
private meetings and working up pretty
much until her due date we're probably
not going to see Megan out on an
official engagement until and after that
royal baby is born baby Sussex is
expected to arrive in late April or
early May and a royal source tells ET
that the Duchess is starting to prepare
for maternity leave and a move to the
English countryside quote Megan and
Harry are expected to move into Frogmore
relatively soon again so they can be
settled before the baby comes
Frogmore is the cottage the couple has
been renovating in Windsor since last
fall they are relocating from Kensington
Palace the adventure of a lifetime
but while Megan might be winding down
her official engagements our source says
she remains determined and focused on
her duties adding that she's still doing
quite a lot behind the scene she's a new
challenge it's something it's a new
chapter right according to our source
Megan and Harry are really excited as
our Prince William and Duchess Kate for
the new addition to the family if Megan
is looking for advice when it comes to
raising a royal baby then of course you
know she doesn't have to look any
further than Kate that said I don't
think that they have the sort of close
relationship where when Megan is
necessarily seeking advice from Kate the
expectant mom has a whole team of mom
friends for that I think the advice that
megan has been taking has actually been
from her close friends Amal Clooney
Serena Williams Jessica Mulroney of
course the friends that she shared her
baby shower with certainly she's been
talking to them about her plans how she
wants to raise this baby
well the sisters-in-law may not be thick
as thieves were told they definitely
have a mutual understanding they both
realize that the idea of a feud you know
a royal cat fight
between two duchesses doesn't help any
of them least of all the two of them and
they've really made an effort to put on
a united front and I think that's what
we were seeing at yesterday's
Commonwealth service we actually saw
Kate kiss Megan hello then when they
greeted each other there was a really
really warm energy between the two of
them but what will the arrival of bebe
Sussex plus Megan in here he's moved to
Frogmore mean for the Duchess's the end
the Fab Four well we'll see less of the
Fab Four together that's not to say that
we're not going to see and William Kate
Megan and Harry doing engagements
together of course they're still a part
of the Royal Foundation that's their
charity forum we'll see them doing those
things together but I think we're
increasingly going to see the Sussex is
doing their thing
the Cambridge is doing their thing the
instruction I'm told from the top which
is with Prince William is there should
be no treading on toes there's plenty of
work for all of them but they're each
going to carve their own niche and I
think you're already seeing them do that
so this move away from Kensington Palace
for Megan and Harry feels like the next
natural step in that change
you